Lisa Vanderpump congratulations TomTom
yeah thank you
we're here it's opened it's beautiful I
feel like well first of all I know this
is your 35th in the world
congratulations on that but every
location you have has a unique
experience attached to it so what was
the inspiration for this one oh that's
what I love about this is just creating
different ambiance and decorating them
all differently and as you say they all
have their own identity it was really
working with Nick Elaine because
normally Ken and I work alone and then
working with him he had such wonderful
creative ideas about you know like all
the kind of master Nations behind the
bar and the clockwork and the gears and
the wonderful kind of lighting fixtures
were really pretty inspiring so yeah we
just kind of got together and it was
just like a brainstorming situation and
we came up with this yeah what means you
choose Tom and Tom out of all the caf I
think that Tom Sandoval had worked with
me you know for a long time and I like
to see progress and I like to see
evolution and I think you know he would
really bring something a unique kind of
younger energy as well to the bar and
then Schwartz I don't think in all the
years I've ever known Schwartz and it's
been 10 years or so that I've really
ever heard anybody apart from his wife's
their negative word about him he's one
of the most likable lovable characters
so I think the fact that they were best
friends and I thought of the name Tom
Tom I thought what a great kind of new
energy it would bring it's memorable in
terms of creative input was there
anything that they suggested or wanted
and you were like no no I'm sure along
the way there were things that I kind of
overruled them but there were other
things that you know they would say what
about the merchandise I said just go do
it you know have fun with it you know
they're cocktail lists and things like
that they really had a good time kind of
Express
Mansingh but when it comes to all the
things that we've been doing for years
you know it was they were part of the
whole process and watched it you know
and they I think really enjoyed that but
when it came to design we had very firm
ideas but I knew they'd love it and when
they first walk in here they were
absolutely blown away would you be
interested in collaborating with any
other stars from Batman we don't
normally have partners it was unusual
that we have partners in sir but you
know I never know what's around the
corner I never thought in a million
years that Schwartz and Sanibel would
actually be our partners in anything if
you'd ask me seven years ago partners in
crime maybe so season seven Vanderpump
rules
will we see Tom Tom on the season at all
oh absolutely you're gonna see the
progress you're gonna see us come back
to Tom Tom we were delayed quite a while
because of some personal circumstance
that I had to deal with so we were
really delayed for quite a few weeks and
then you see us come back it was a bit
of a slow start for me at the beginning
of the season but the season is
jam-packed it's a lot of fun I love it
when you have an authentic storyline and
you know I think that's what we always
try to do on Vanderpump rules follow the
true story and this was the true story
as we were shooting so yeah it was a lot
of fun and you see it come to fruition
which is always great yeah so seven
seasons you we've watched the cast grow
up and you're kind of like their fairy
godmother in a lot of respects obviously
Tom Tom now being brought on as business
partners but with someone like Lala now
being in the row that's really cool as
an actor have you got a chance to see
the film I haven't seen the film I was
away when she had her premiere but you
know I just love to see them kind of
really evolve and - as you say grow up
mature and start making kind of more
interesting saner choices as you seen
the show you know it's it's yeah I think
it's almost like you feel a sense of
pride really when you see them doing
well yeah and then Jackson Britney now
being engaged
I think Britney is the best thing that
ever happened Jax Taylor
oh I hope he remembers that every single
day